[Música]
ah
buenas tardes a todos
ese soy yo en caída libre y ahí pase la
mitad de mi vida hace 17 años que soy
paracaidista y que me dedico de manera
exclusiva al deporte en mi pasión
obviamente la cual tengo de la suerte de
compartir con muchos de mis amigos es mi
trabajo porque vivo de esto y es mi
responsabilidad porque soy parte del
equipo argentino de una de las
disciplinas del deporte con la cual
representamos al país
pero más allá de todo y por sobre todo
esto soy un agradecido de haber podido
vivir este deporte de manera tan plena
de manera tan intensa desde adentro
porque estoy convencido de que el parqué
mismo me enseñó a vivir un poco mejor
en este tiempo en el cual estuve
saltando hizo un poco más de 4000 saltos
que si transformamos eso a una medida de
distancia en caída libre son más de ocho
mil kilómetros es la distancia que hay
entre buenos aires y johannesburgo en
sudáfrica sería como cruzar el océano
atlántico en caída libre es mucho
recorrido no mucha distancia
pero aún así me acuerdo de los primeros
metros de estos primeros encuentros con
el vacío y lo que eso me generaba
y hoy como instructor
me encuentro o sea generando nuevos
paracaidistas y haciendo saltos de
bautismos que la gente que salta por
única vez me encuentro con muchas
primeras veces en caída libre
[Música]
y lo que le genera a las personas esos
encuentros quiero compartir con ustedes
algunos obviamente de esos encuentros de
esos primeros encuentros con el vacío
[Música]
qué locura no
desde el momento en que se abre la
puerta del avión y tenemos que dar ese
primer paso para saltar nuestro cuerpo
empieza a generar un combo de
sensaciones
muchas muchas veces muy difíciles de
describir en primer lugar porque nacimos
con piernas diseñados para caminar
no tenemos alas y no podemos volar
hacemos algo parecido jugamos a volar
pero no podemos volar en serio y en
segundo lugar porque pasamos de estar
dentro del avión que es un habitáculo
con límites reales por decirlo alguna
manera para nuestro cuerpo una situación
que fácilmente podemos reconocer
a un ambiente completamente desconocido
en el cual nos podemos mover en todas
las direcciones en todas las dimensiones
y al mismo tiempo estamos cayendo 200
kilómetros por hora
sentimos que estamos apoyados en el aire
nuestro cuerpo está generando adrenalina
a mansalva
nos sentimos extasiados y queremos que
en ese momento no hay nada mejor
pero sucede sorprendentemente no sucedió
a todos los que continuamos saltando que
el poco tiempo esas sensaciones que
parecen ser insuperables son superadas
por una nueva
y es el hecho de saltar con otra persona
de compartir eso claro no lo puede
explicar ven y saltamos y lo compartimos
ahora bien yo como para que esto
individual tengo mi rol
mi responsabilidad que es hacer un salto
seguro conocer el equipo que voy a usar
a saber a la altura en la que estoy y
abrir mi par caídas cuando corresponde
básicamente pero ahora hay una nueva
variable que es que hay otra persona en
el aire y por más grande que parezca el
cielo a 200 kilómetros por hora las
distancias se acortan bastante y yo no
puedo abrirle el para que ellas en la
cara del otro paracaidista
obviamente porque la única manera que
digamos que ese salto fue bueno es si
después de divertirnos y después de
aterrizar estamos los dos sanos y salvos
el paracaidismo nos exige estar 100%
conscientes del otro durante la
actividad
bien dijimos que esta sensación
intensamente liberadora que significa
saltar de un avión es potenciada aún más
cuando se comparte con otra persona
qué pasa si son muchas otras personas
hay una disciplina en la cual tuve la
suerte de participar que se llama
grandes formaciones y como su nombre lo
indica es una figura en este caso en
caída libre formada por varios
paracaidistas que salen sueltos de uno o
varios aviones y vuelan hacia un punto
en común para agarrarse
en el caso de la foto hay 30 para que
vistas podemos hacerlo de 50 vamos a
hacerlo de 100 pero vamos en un caso en
un caso en particular concreto el récord
mundial es de 400 paracaidistas es una
única formación de 400 paracaidistas en
caída libre son 5 aviones gigantes
desparramando gente por el aire
imagínense las logísticas que se
necesita para ordenar estas 400 personas
a 200 kilómetros por hora en pos de
lograr esta formación de manera ordenada
y segura porque llegada determinada a
determinada altura los paracaidistas
tienen que alejarse de la formación y de
los otros y estar lo más lejos posible
para abrir sus paracaídas porque como
dijimos antes no le podemos abrir el
paracaídas en la cara a otro
aparecen entonces técnicas individuales
que tiene que tener cada paracaidista
para participar en una formación de
estas y técnicas grupales que tiene que
ver con ser parte de esta formación
vamos hablar de esas técnicas grupales y
acá donde los invito a que hagan sus
analogías y que saquen sus propias
conclusiones de porque creo que el
paracaidismo me enseñó a vivir mejor
porque en este caso
las grandes formaciones son figuras en
calle libre sí pero tranquilamente puede
ser nuestra familia puede ser nuestro
grupo de amigos la sociedad el planeta
en el que vivimos estas reglas grupales
esas técnicas grupales aplican a
cualquier formación que perciba un fin
en común
en estas formaciones en calle libre
estas figuras cada paracaidista tiene un
único lugar asignado en otro es decir
que esa formación que nibali de cada uno
está en su lugar y en base a ese lugar
se decide la ubicación dentro del avión
y el momento de la salida
en la pasada final del avión que es el
momento de que los parquistas empiecen a
saltar
empieza a salir los primeros que ya
empiezan a caer mientras el año siga
avanzando
luego sale la base que no es ni más ni
menos que una formación más pequeña de 4
o 5 paracaidistas que ya salen agarrados
y adonde todos van a volar para luego
agarrarse mientras el avión sigue
volando
y salen los últimos que quedan por
arriba y pasados de la base
como vemos entonces para empezar no
todos partimos del mismo punto para
llevar un objetivo todos estamos a
diferentes niveles y para seguir
dado que yo tengo un único lugar
asignado en esa formación tengo que
desde el lugar donde estoy y con las
responsabilidades que tengo desde ese
lugar si es abajo juntar todo el aire
necesario para flotar me para subir a
esa formación si es arriba soltar todo
el aire necesario con mi responsabilidad
es llegar hasta mi lugar
sin interferir en el vuelo de los demás
tengo que buscar mi lugar en la
formación mi cuadrante desde afuera y
volar en línea recta sin interferir en
el camino de los demás porque de lo
contrario si yo llego a la formación me
agarro que mi fin primero llegar y
agarrarme pero interferir en el vuelo de
otros estoy a trazando que esta
formación se realice
cuántas veces en la vida vamos ciegos
hacia el objetivo y nos olvidamos que
alrededor nuestro hay otros que también
quiere llegar
y sólo si todos llegamos el fin último
es el pleno si no no tiene sentido
hay otra regla o técnica grupal que
tiene que ver con el momento de llegar a
la formación ni antes ni después hay un
momento
dijimos que hay una altura de seguridad
se acuerdan en la cual los paracaidistas
empiezan a separarse para abrir sus
paracaídas de manera segura tengo que
llegar antes que eso obviamente pero de
nada sirve salir del avión volar más
rápido que los otros para que están
pasarlo llegar primero a la formación
y estar bloqueando el camino al que iba
delante mío obligándolo a él a tener que
interrumpir el vuelo de los demás
siento que vivimos en una eterna en una
constante competencia donde lo
importante es
ser mejor que los demás
siempre todo el tiempo
y muchas veces como en este caso
no sirve de nada ser el primero en
llegar sirve ser el que más suma a la
causa hay un momento para todo
otra de las técnicas grupales que
existen en esta disciplina tiene que ver
con el momento en que yo me voy a
agarrar a la formación que yo voy a ser
parte de esa formación
lo tengo que hacer a nivel qué quiere
decir esto tengo que igualar la
velocidad de la formación en el caso de
las figuras en calle libre porque si yo
me apoyo arriba de la formación por el
solo hecho de querer agarrar mi lugar
que era lo que yo quería mi objetivo mi
fin primero o si yo me cuelgo desde
abajo en la formación en ambos casos voy
a estar hundiendo y no solamente
hundiendo el de adelante sino todo un
sector porque estaban agarrados y ellos
habían llegado
cuántas veces pasa y a mí me pasa me ha
pasado
de depositar la responsabilidad en
nuestras caídas en los demás y la
realidad es que llegamos hasta donde
estamos volando por nuestra cuenta
por nuestra cuenta bajo nuestras propias
técnicas individuales o creencias o
convicciones como queramos llamarle pero
es nuestra responsabilidad igualar a él
el nivel de la formación que yo voy a
agarrar no de los demás en nuestra
ahora bien
sucede que si yo llego a la formación me
agarro supongamos
y llegué sin interferir en el camino de
nadie
y louis en el momento adecuado y tome la
formación a nivel me comporte como un
buen ciudadano del aire y como yo otros
paracaidistas hacen lo mismo son otros
buenos ciudadanos del aire y lleven a la
formación interrumpieron a nadie ocurre
que la formación empieza a crecer y se
empieza a formar una especie de red
humana que atrapa más aire y eso hace
que caiga más lento incluso más lento
que los paracaidistas que aún no
llegaron y a quienes se le va a ser
prácticamente imposible llegar
aparece entonces una nueva técnica
grupal que no es más importante que las
anteriores pero si desde mi punto de
vista es más significativa
y tiene que ver con pensar en el otro
tiene que ver con el momento en el que
yo ya llegué a la formación ya logré mi
fin primero es ahí donde no me puedo
relajar es ahí donde donde tengo que
aplicar todas mis técnicas individuales
para caer más rápido donde tengo que
tener
una posición sólida frente a la
situación para acelerar esa formación y
que el otro poder llegar y si todos los
demás paracaidistas que fueron llegando
acá está en esa técnica grupal
la formación se cierra
hay una pregunta que yo siempre me hacía
cuando veía a aterrizar paracaidistas
luego de un salto de formación y
festejaban que lo habían logrado
yo me preguntaba bueno como el que está
en un medio y tal vez de espaldas al
último que cerró esa formación sabe que
esa formación se cerró
y cuando pude participar ese tipo de
saltos me di cuenta que en realidad no
se sabe sino que en realidad se siente
porque la formación esa está en paz
cuando la formación se está armando
esta especie de caos está agitada porque
hay gente llegando desde abajo juntando
todo el aire necesario para llegar hay
gente llegando desde arriba soltando
todo el aire que puede para llegar hay
algunos que ya llegaron y están dando
velocidad la formación para que el otro
llegue y hay algunos que llegaron y
están relajados entonces se genera una
especie de olas humanas lo que hace
dudoso el momento de entrar porque esto
lo tengo que hacer a nivel entonces
complica ese momento
pero solamente cuando todos se dan
cuenta que la única forma de lograr el
fin último y de que ese fin último sea
pleno es ayudando a que el otro llegue
esta formación cierra
esa familia se consolida esa sociedad
avanza ese planeta respira respira
porque está en paz esa paz que tal vez
estemos buscando y que no se sabe cuándo
llegan
sino que se sienten
muchas gracias por su tiempo
[Aplausos]
[Música]